[Musica]
Eccoci qui
Monica come essere qui a casa però è una
casa emozionante molto molto Sono
felicissima di essere qua però
come è stato detto ho parlato un po'
dappertutto però qui veramente lo sento
di più perché mi sento proprio con degli
amici con delle persone che mi rende
molto molto emozionata Ecco benissimo la
sentite in sala si sente bene No allora
vediamo se ci danno una mano dalla regia
perché questa intervista ovviamente
merita tutta di essere sentita Monica
una vita Incredibile la tua e che parla
anche di un bel progetto è un bel
messaggio anche di empowerment femminile
Unica donna a lavorare sulla F40 subito
la domanda che ti pongono anche in tanti
e Comè nata la tua passione e quanto
hanno contato le tue radici per tutto
ciò Allora io la mia passione è partita
da piccolissima perché in casa mia Avevo
mio zio che lavorava a reparto corsi lui
in Formula 2 Il papà anche lavorava
anche lui quindi in casa mia si parlava
e si respira solo l'area della Ferrari
di Enzo Ferrari di quest'uomo che
veramente non so riempiva di sogni la
gente in cui lavoravano lì Diciamo in
Ferrari e anche nel paese io sentendo
sempre parlare di diciamo di questo di
quest'uomo delle sue macchine a me mi
entravano dentro Cioè io non so eran una
cosa più forte di me quindi poi in casa
nostro venivano anche ingegneri venivano
anche alcuni piloti quindi si respirava
sempre quest'area quindi Quindi io
dicevo No io devo fare il meccanico Io
voglio fare il meccanico alla Ferrari e
il mio sogno era solo quello io dovevo
riuscire a entrare in Ferrari a fare il
meccanico non in ufficio Ci sarei
entrato lo stesso anche se mi avrebbero
proposto l'ufficio ma io volevo volevo
assolutamente fare il meccanico
quindi diciamo dopo niente Ho iniziato a
fare le scuole qui a a Maranello che ho
fatto un anno e poi quando sono stata
chiamata io sono stata felicissima di
entrare a far parte della Ferrari che
diciamo nel in quel periodo lì ce
n'erano perché delle donne ce n'erano
erano in tappezzeria oppure erano in
finizione a farle alcune in ufficio
farle insomma lavoro di segreteria anche
amministrativo però diciamo avevano
provato da quel che mi avevano detto
anche dov'ero poi andata io in
carrozzeria Eh ma insomma c'erano c'era
anche tanta fatica e tanto lavoro un po'
un po' impegnativo Ecco e Evolution con
te la domanda che subito mi è venuto in
mente era legato da una parte al mondo
dei motori dall'altra anche al ruolo tuo
Cioè quanto è cambiato il ruolo della
donna nell'ambito dei motori e anche ti
chiedo invece si parla tanto di
evoluzione quindi tra autoelettriche
idrogeno Insomma è un mondo diversissimo
da quando hai iniziato tu sì allora un
mondo diversissimo perché io quando sono
entrata i miei attrezzi Diciamo erano il
trapano
l'avvitatore delle chiavi avevamo e
dovevamo F tutto a mano perché io dovevo
andare in meccanica subito ma m'hanno
messo poi in carrozzeria per
un'emergenza Quindi mi Avo per dire il
il lavoro una stazione durava quasi
un'ora e un quarto quanto ero entrata io
e facendo tutto a mano prendo un esempio
da un per dire l'asta della sicura che
ce ne davano la misura era questa per
tutte le le porte diciamo però c'erano
le varie versioni usa o o altri Stati
che avevano delle omologazioni diverse
quindi si doveva dare solo una normale
asta della sicura si doveva dare delle
insomma piegarlo in un modo che andasse
sempre che chiudesse e e si aprissi Ecco
e noi questo per dire questo semplice
lavoro che può sembrare semplice ma lo
ricavava tante piegature
tante piegature in morsa a volte si
rompevano dovevamo andare anche a
saldare ci avevano insegnato anche a
saldare per dire una punta ci doveva
durare un bel po' ci avevano insegnato
proprio anche a a limar Insomma ad
arrivare Cioè non rimare non è proprio
la parola giusta ma adesso mi manca la
parola però insomma dovevamo portarle al
punto sempre che finché non ce ne maneva
un pezzettino che ci permettevano di
andarne a prendere un'altra adesso è
anche la fatica fisica ci sporcavo tanto
e c'era Noi facevamo tutto a mano quindi
adesso l'evoluzione sono Sono molto
contenta che ci sia non soprattutto
anche per le donne Perché dove diciamo
Io avevo la difficoltà della fatica
fisica perché io ero una donna quindi la
mia difficoltà l'avevo però dicevo
vedevo che mi guardavano un attimo
adesso non ce la fa però la passione che
avevo e l'amore che avevo per il mio
lavoro e volevo assolutamente farcela mi
faceva fare anche degli sforzi delle
volte enormi ma però questo mi è servito
a avere la loro fiducia cioè io volevo
dimostrare agli uomini della Ferrari a
questi meccanici meravigliosi che per me
erano stati Fonte anche della mia
passione m hanno aiutato anche loro a a
far crescere quello che io sentivo per
la Ferrari e le sue macchine Quindi
diciamo io non so come dire mi mi dava
la forza di tirar su anche dei pesi
impossibili Quindi secondo me l'
evoluzione in quel campo qua e diciamo
della nella
donna mi sento di dire che la la porta
fare anche delle cose dove io a un certo
punto gli uomini mi venivano anche a
aiutare questo mi faceva un enorme
piacere perché quando loro facevano
questi gesti era perché credevano in te
in quello che facevi nella tua manualità
Quindi per me che adesso ci siano
l'evoluzione abbia portato a agevolare
anche il lavoro di una donna quindi può
andare anche oltre in Insomma dove ero
io a lavorare Secondo me è una cosa e si
vede anche si vede quindi possono adesso
fanno cose in più che che non facevo
neanch'io Quindi anche il prodotto è
diventato migliore perché l'evoluzione
ha portato anche a fare il prodotto
abbastanza insomma perché noi facevamo
tutto manualmente quindi non sempre le
macchine erano uguali quindi Però noi ci
dicevano che erano era il suo bello
nella Ferrari era una macchina anche
diversa dall'altra perché c'era diciamo
la mano dell'uomo e tante volte noi non
è che eravamo sempre in forma nel
lavorare perché eravamo esseri umani
quindi non sempre le cose venivano
perfette e per me l'evoluzione Anche qua
ha portato che diciamo il prodotto sia
sempre uguale e quindi insomma anche
visivamente molto più più bello Ecco da
vedere Hai detto bene Tra l'altro ho in
mente anche una una un termine di taler
quell della spinta gentile Perché tu
così Sei riuscita poi ad abbattere delle
barriere come hai fatto Ma innanzitutto
sono entrata con un'umiltà
incredibile perché ci vuole l'umiltà
quando si deve imparare qualcosa quando
non e e vuoi riuscirci quindi io ho
portato il massimo rispetto a questi
meccanici che per me veramente erano
unici al mondo a questi tecnici
veramente per me eccezionali Quindi con
l'umiltà e con la voglia che io volevo
fargli vedere che io volevo con le mie
capacità e che vedessero che sapevo
anche se ero una donna a fare quello che
facevano loro
e praticamente loro li ho un attimo
diciamo anche se vedevo in loro che
dicevano ma adesso vediamo così però
dopo erano sempre lì che mi aiutavano
Anzi m' hanno aperto hanno capito chi
ero la mia passione e devo dire che dopo
mi hanno aperto tutto Cioè mi portavano
ovunque con loro e mi insegnavano tutto
e mi hanno punto dato dopo 8 anni la
possibilità di poter andare a lavorare
sull' F40 perché quando sono stata
chiamata in ufficio e dal responsabile
della carrozzeria e lì Diciamo non lo
dico perché voglio farmi grande però lì
ho capito qualcosa che forse sapevo fare
qualcosa e avevo una buona manualità
perché subito ci avevano chiamato in
quattro c'ero io e altre tre persone
e quindi per me è stata una una cosa
eccezionale poter lavorare su questa
macchina è così importante perché per
noi quando ci dicevano che era una cosa
voluta anche dal commendator Ferrari Noi
facevamo tutto ed era la nostra forza
cioè noi lavoravamo come se fosse nostro
ed è quello che ci faceva proprio
Secondo me distinguere da tanti da tante
altre cose perché noi Secondo me era
proprio una cosa che sentivamo nostra e
quando ami una cosa e la passione non
non non si riesce a non fare una bella
cosa il tuo desiderio più grande Va
detto però che era quello di entrare nel
mondo delle corse e qui non ci sei
riuscita è stata È stata dura Sì cioè
qui praticamente perché poi il mio sogno
era dover andare in Formula 1 Io volevo
andare lì però mi mi andava già bene
essere in Ferrari quindi però diciamo
non c'era una volta o due al mesi che
non andassi all'ufficio personale
chiederei Ma posso andare c'è cambiato
qualcosa no lì è impossibile non si può
per tanti motivi Perché dicevano la
fatica si lavorava di notte
e poi insomma Veramente anche mi hanno
detto anche mi dicevano anche il
discorso logistico per la camera in più
e di qua di là insomma erano era
difficile veramente lì ma lì capivo
anche sinceramente non è ero io che non
non riuscivo a non dargliela chiedere
perché ci volevo andare e facevo di
tutto perché avevo una spinta dentro una
passione che insomma io credevo di
farcela anche lì non so perché come
anche adesso mi sentirei mi è mancata
questo diciamo questa prova di mettermi
alla prova anche lì Però devo dire che
proprio perché capivano questa mia
passione diciamo una volta o due
all'anno mi ci mandavano dei mesi di là
a lavorare che loro era per loro darmi
un premio per tutto la insomma la mia
Diciamo
Mh per quello che avevo già dato in
Ferrari per quello che stavo dando
Quindi diciamo non potevano mettermi Lì
però mi mi davano la possibilità di
andare a lavorare diciamo quando c'erano
le presentazioni delle macchine in pista
Fiorano o davanti all'officina perché
allora si la macchina la Formula 1 si
presentava metà marzo febbraio marzo mi
sembra e campionato anche volte già
iniziato e praticamente le presentavano
davanti anche a volte alla gestione
sportiva Ecco quindi mi hanno dato tra
virgolette non ci sono riusciti in
Ferrari perché io avrei voluto riuscirci
lì e poi mi davo mandavano i box come
regali mi facevano queste cose che per
me poi era mi accontentavo dicevo mi lo
facevo andar bene diciamo Ecco vorrei
chiudere con una domanda difficile
Monica perché tu hai conosciuto
personalmente Enzo Ferrari che potremmo
anche definire Oggi più che mai un
imprenditore moderno imprenditori fra
l'altro si riconoscono anche nei momenti
di grande difficoltà Recentemente un
anno in particolare è finito sotto
riflettori quel
1957 che è stato riportato nel film a
Venezia in prima mondiale di Michael
Mann e ti chiedo come avrebbe
interpretato lui l'evoluzione Secondo te
in questo momento Allora secondo me
mediatore era una persona che
sicuramente sarebbe stato al passo con
l'evoluzione
sicuramente Però mi viene anche da dire
che lui amava
talmente quando anche le nasceva una
macchina un semplice disegno
e era talmente bello anche creare un
pezzo montarlo e tutto e avere questo
suono del motore avere tutte queste cose
qui che secondo me lui sicuramente
sarebbe andata con l'evoluzione però non
non so fino a che punto Ecco però questo
io mio parere personale conoscendo un
po' vedendo come amava e insomma queste
vetture e che anima avevano queste
vetture quindi Però io non da quel lato
lì è solo mio parere personale perché io
ci sono persone che lo conoscono e ci
sono stati proprio stretto contatto a
lavorare con lui che forse questa
domanda sono più bravi loro a rispondere
di me posso solo dare un par persono
molto bello degli occhiali scuri Chiari
ce lo vuoi raccontare Ma sì appunto
perché mi mandavano i box a vedere le
gare quando lo chiedevo e così avevo
fatto delle foto a gilin neev e molto
belle ne ho fatti anche altri però
purtroppo nell'82 era morto Jill e io
insomma dicevano che non stava tanto
bene che soffriva per questa cosa Allora
siccome c'era una forte amicizia con
Dino il suo autista che per me è molto
riduttivo dire autista perché era il suo
l'uomo che era sempre con lui poi era
Insomma non lo lasciava mai lui si
fidava molto di lui quindi un giorno gli
ho detto Dino ma mi piacerebbe che il
commendatore vedesse queste foto che ho
scattato a Gil allora lui detto Sì sì
Gliele porto Gliele porto poi gliele ha
portate poi mi ha detto tra due tre
giorni poi ti dico qualcosa Infatti m'ha
chiamato e miha detto passa a prenderle
quando esci dala sera dal lavoro passa a
prenderle Allora io sono passata sono
andata a casa Mi sono cambiata perché
facevo parte della squadra tennis
Ferrari e c'avevamo Gli allenamenti sono
attac Car mi sono infilata una tutta
veloce Poi sono corsa in via Scari
perché erano appena appena andati
Nell'ufficio nuovo di via Scari arrivo
lì mi fa il guardiano Ok Entra pure no
Come entra Io prendo le foto mi han
detto vieni a prendere le foto io dopo
Guarda come son messa no no no no devi
entrare allora hanno riferito Dino che
non non la sentivo di entrare è venuta a
prendermi fa No devi entrare allora sono
entrata mi ha accompagnato e nel suo
studio sono entrata Praticamente sono
rimasta pietrificata anche se noi lo
vedevamo praticamente tutti i giorni
quando entrava in officina ma un conto
vederlo tutti i giorni salutarlo Un
conto trovarci lì di fronte e ero
rimasto in piedi avevo Gozzi qui alla
mia destra mi ha detto Beh n salute
Menga cioè che in italiano Beh non lo
saluti allora io gli ho detto l'ho
salutato poi mi ha fatto accomodare e
niente poi ha voluto sapere della mia
passione ho voluto sapere perché volevo
entrare assolutamente in Ferrari che non
lo sto ripet l'avete sentito anche prima
quindi tutte queste cose qua poi dopo mi
fa Ma ha chiesto a Gozzi e Det you cera
fa Mi dai gli Chiari Chiari io lì per lì
non ho fatto caso questa cosa detto
forse per vederci un po' meglio non ho
fatto caso a questa cosa e niente e poi
dopo mi ha chiesto se avevo qualcosa io
di suo gli ho detto detto di sì però fa
dai con gozi vai a prendere una foto
ehm mia che mi ha voluto lasciare un una
dedica di quella sera lì c'era mi
ricordo nella foto Arn tambè ma c' ha
fatto Ferrari 83 con quella famoso
inchiostro e suo e quindi poi vabbè io
la semplifico molto ma abbiamo parlato
di di tante cose dopo a un certo punto è
arrivato dentro un suo stretto
collaboratore e ha detto C'è uno che sta
aspettando è già passato tanto tempo fa
mai B Le passai un'ora lui ha detto è
già passata un'ora
e e lui ha detto sì allora dopo lì ci
siamo salutati però Ecco una cosa che mi
mi è scappata quando è passato diciamo
ai Chiari che ho visto i suoi occhi e
che il suo sorriso
ehm è una cosa che ancora adesso mentre
ne parlo faccio Mi sembra di averlo
ancora di fronte dal Gran che è stata
una cosa veramente Almeno per me
grossissima e dopo ci siamo salutati di
mi ha accompagnato la la porta e vedevo
che mi diceva hai visto che è passato
gli occhiali chiari Gli ho detto sì ho
visto che è passato gli occhiali Chiari
Alfa Ma sai quando perché passa dagli
occhiali Chiari a scuri ho detto boh io
so che ci dicono che porta gli occhiali
scuri perché lui ha una forma che vuole
quando non conosce una persona ci
dicevano così a noi che aveva un po'
imbarazzo non si voleva far vedere
com'era e voleva capire chi aveva di
fronte senza farsi Insomma scoprire lui
Ecco diciamo E allora Dio mi fa Sì può
essere vero però sorridendo mi ha detto
Guarda quando passa dagli occhiali scuri
ai Chiari è perché ha di fronte a sé è
una persona sincera che l'ha messo a suo
agio e si può fidare Vi giuro
Sono veramente le parole che mi ha detto
Perché non me le dimenticherò mai e
anche adesso mi sembra di essere lì
anche adesso mi è venuta una forte
emozione nel pensare a questa cosa
non sono più andata all'allenamento mi
dovevo godere questa magia quindi
proprio assolutamente non me la sono
proprio sentita
e E quest me la porterò sempre con me
perché è un regalo grosso che mi hanno
fatto sempre i suoi collaboratori sempre
i meccanici sempre devo devo tutto loro
Ecco grazie Allora Monica Zanetti anche
per la grande sincerità e spontaneità in
questa sua intervista C posso salutar
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
D